depuis quinze jours rien ne bouge rien
ne bouge rien ne bouge donc aujourd'hui
j'ai décidé de pousser vraiment un coup
de gueule parce que suite à ces
décisions de la poste il ya un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens qui sont en
grande difficulté
le sujet le plus important et le plus
urgent ce sont les personnes vulnérables
qui sont confinés des personnes âgées
qui sont dans les hameaux dans des
maisons isolées et qui pour certaines
d'entre elles n'ont pas de moyen de
paiement moderne de type de cartes
bancaires ou même de chéquier
j'ai testé pour vous avec des personnes
âgées les moyens duction qu'on m'a
proposé
alors tout d'abord vous présenter devant
le bureau de poste à martigny vous avez
une affiche qui vous indiquent en raison
de la fermeture des établissements
scolaires
nous ne sommes pas en mesure d'assurer
un fonctionnement normal du bureau
vis-à-vis de nos équipes de personnel et
on vous donne les coordonnées du site
internet de la poste
vous pensez fait effectivement que les
grands pères qui ont 80 ans
ils vont se connecter sur le site
www.laposte.fr ou où la banque postale
point fr donc c'est totalement inadapté
et incohérent ensuite on m'a proposé le
numéro unique alors je vous conseille de
numéro 10 que j'ai testé moi même avec
une personne de 85 donc le 36 31
alors faites fait le numéro unique vous
allez voir tapez 1 tapez 2 tapez 3 taper
9 refaites le 38 je ne sais quoi
et au bout d'une demi heure vous avez la
personne âgée qui vous rappellent
complètement paniqué et qui vous dit
mais je sais plus quoi faire donc c'est
totalement inadapté ensuite on m'a
proposé de mettre un papier sur la boîte
aux lettres pour indiquer aux facteurs
que la personne âgée en difficulté avait
des besoins
sauf que aujourd'hui le facteur il va
pas passer dans votre boîte aux lettres
tous les jours et comme en plus la poste
a eu là l'idée lumineuse de réduire ses
tournées et de les concentrer sur trois
jours le mercredi le jeudi et le
vendredi
si vous avez un besoin de samedi ou le
lundi
et bien vous n'avez pas de facteurs qui
passe avant plusieurs jours en dernier
recours on m'a proposé d'envoyer les
coordonnées précises des personnes avec
leurs coordonnées de leur compte postal
à mon interlocuteur privilégié à la
poste j'ai testé pour vous avec
plusieurs personnages et de ma commune
les quinze jours qu'elles attendent leur
argent donc c'est intolérable c'est
intolérable que la poste se comporte de
la sorte avec des personnes vulnérables
donc on fait du bricolage on travaille
avec les commerçants qui font crédit
nous mêmes en tant qu'élu on dépanne on
donne de l'argent aux pays dans le
besoin mais c'est pas tenable dans la
durée au niveau de la mairie on a mis en
place un service d'écouté avec mes
adjointes
nous avons une vingtaine de personnages
et sur la commune que nous appelons
plusieurs fois par semaine on a mis en
place un service de portage de course de
portage de médicaments
moi ce que je demande c'est qu'il ya un
service minimum avec une présence
humaine qui permettent d'assurer les
urgences plusieurs jours par semaine sur
le territoire et je demande à ce qu'ils
aient une attention particulière pour
les personnes vulnérables pour qu'on
puisse trouver un dispositif simple
efficace qui permette aux gens sont à
leur domicile qui sont confinés aux
personnes âgées qui ne peuvent pas se
déplacer de pouvoir grâce au réseau des
facteurs bénéficier d'un minimum
d'argent en dépannage pour leurs
dépenses quotidiennes
voilà